翻訳: Nicolas Toumayan
校正: Riaki Poništ
僕は20年くらい前に
100人くらい いる設計事務所で
働いてたんです
その時 作ってた建築っていうのは
お金を稼ぐために作っていました
また 歴史的に見ても
建築っていうのは
お金のある人のために
また ある時は権力のある人のために
作っていたっていうのも事実です
ところが 今僕たちが作っている
建築っていうのは
クライアントの方々の事業が
成立するっていうことは
当然前提なんですけれども
その事業主の方の周りの方々も
幸せになるような
建築っていうのを作っています
なんか ちょっと青臭いことって
思われるかもしれませんが
それは本当で
それは2012年の
沖縄の仕事から始まりました
今日はちょっと そんなお話を
させていただこうかと思います
2012年 沖縄の糸満というところで
レストランを作る話がありました
糸満というところは
昔から栄えている漁港で
ところが今やっぱり元気なくなって
市場なんかにもシャッターが
どんどん増えてきてる
という状況がありました
クライアントの玉城さんは
おばあさんが漁民だったということもあって
なんとか彼らの食文化を伝えるために
レストランを作りたい
というふうに考えていたんです
で 僕たちリサーチをしました
そうすると糸満の地面 地層が
琉球石灰岩というのが分かってきました
なんとかこれを使って
糸満らしい建築ができないかなと考えて
こういう絵を描いたんですね
まず地面があって
そこを掘ると
琉球石灰岩が出てきます
それを ちょっとずつ積んで
山を作って
一枚の屋根だけかけると
場所ができる
なんかそういう 伸び伸びとした
沖縄らしい建築が
できないかなというふうに考えて
こんな絵を描いたんですけれども
なんとなく これにちょっと
違和感がありまして
本当にこういう建築が
玉城さんの想いに応えられているのかなと
そういうふうに思っていたんですけれども
ある日 玉城さんがこれを見て
おじいさんとか おばあさんが
こういうふうに漁場を作ったんだ
というふうに思い出してくれたんです
そして実際に
３日間で60名の地域の方々と
一緒に石を積んで建物を作りました
彼ら 自分たちの未来のために
自分たちの手で
作った建物です
内壁も琉球石灰岩で出来ています
僕は これが みんなで一緒になって
建築作るってのは初めての経験だったんですね
この沖縄の漁民食堂の
計画が終わった2014年に
千葉県で保育園を作る
計画がありました
そこの敷地は
南にゆるやかに傾斜があって
周りを木々に囲まれた
とても魅力的な場所だったんです
保育園というのは
子どもたちの建物ですから
なんか 僕ら大人が先回りをして
こういうのが子どもたちにとって
いいんじゃないかっていうのはやめたいな
そんなこと思ってたんですけれども
極力 周りがこれだけ恵まれた環境なので
それをそのまま建築にできないか
っていうことを考えたんです
これが その保育園の模型です
これを見ながら
ご説明しようと思いますが
斜面 こう ゆるやかな南向きに
傾斜がついていまして
そこに段々に保育室を配置しています
壁で仕切るのではなくて
それで 風っていうのは南から入って
こう 北に 抜けてくように
大きな一枚の屋根をかけました
屋根が大きいと夏場は暑くなりますから
スプリンクラー 散水装置を
屋根に設置をしてます
一番下の軒は 周りが樹木に囲まれてるから
すぐ詰まっちゃうんですね
ですから雨どい つけていません
そうすると 今言ったスプリンクラーとか
ここに降る雨なんかが
そのまま滝のように落ちていきます
一番下には じゃぶじゃぶ池を設けて
子どもたちが遊べるようなしつらえをしました
同時に ここの
じゃぶじゃぶ池っていうのは
南から入ってくる風を冷やす
冷却装置にもなっています
こんな計画で
建物の中を風がブワーッと通るような
そんな計画だったんです
まぁ 色々な問題が
またこの他にありまして
当然段々になってるから
危ないんじゃないかとか
それから３歳とか５歳
一緒になって過ごしますから
お昼寝の時間が違うんですね
こういうのは良くないんじゃないかって
まぁ そんな問題点も
あったんですけれども
理事長さんたちと
これはが大きな家だという
コンセプトについて話し合ったんです
実は 理事長さん
生まれも育ちも ここのそばで
農家の大きな家で育ったということでした
大きな農家の家—
大きな屋根の大きな家は
間仕切りなんかありませんから
３歳も５歳もお兄ちゃんも弟も
一緒になって過ごしてきたと
古い家には縁側ってあります
縁側くらいの高さより
ちょっと高いんですね この段々が
縁側から落ちて
死んだ奴いないよねっていうことで
そんな話をしながら
この建物 出来ました
外から見ると こういう感じです
段々になっていますから
これみんな
３歳も５歳も ２歳も４歳も
みんな 同じ空間の中で過ごします
横から見るとこういう段差があるんです
下のフロアの保育室を
上の小さい子どもたちが見て—
そういう関係があります
これが風の取り入れ口です
これは とても僕は好きな写真で
遊び疲れた子どもたちが
滝を見て黄昏れてるっていう
こういう感性はちょっと
僕らには思いつかなかったなと思って
見ていました
これは 今 取り組んでいる
介護施設のドローイングです
ここのクライアントは
石井さんといいますが
石井さんがここで考えている
介護施設ってのは
「施設」ではなくて
「家」って呼ぶほうがふさわしいと
そういうお話をしてくれました
おじいちゃんも おばあちゃんも
子どもも 地域の人も
みんな 一緒に入れていいじゃないかと
みんなが自然に集まってくれるような
建物がいいんだと
そういう話をしてくれました
このドローイングで示しているのは
軒が深く出ています
雨が降った日に
雨を楽しめるような
また雨が降ってるときに
一枚の屋根を感じられるような
そういう長い縁側みたいな建物です
またここでは 助け合いをしながら
この建物を運営していこうっていう
考え方に取り組んでいます
つまり それは
近所の 朝ご飯を食べれない状況の
子どもたちがたくさんいるもんですから
「ここの食堂を使ってってもいいよ」
「お風呂ここで入ってってもいいよ」
その代わりに施設の手伝いをして
掃除をして帰ってってもらう
あるいは地域の人たちは
ここの運営 お手伝いしていれば
自分の親の相談も
気軽に乗ってもらえるし
それからまた 将来もうちょっと
大きな家族になったような気分で
少し安心感が増すような
そういう取り組みをしています
石井さんがこんな話して
なんか僕ら
「難しいな イメージできないな」と思って
こんな写真を探してきたんですね
これは江戸時代の錦絵です
この手前にあるのが
「ミセ」と呼ばれる空間です
この「ミセ」と呼ばれる空間には
色んな職業の人
色んな年齢の人たちが
一緒に過ごしていることが
描かれています
これをよくよく見てると僕は
楽しそうだなと思うんですね
なんか こっちの方が日本人には
自然じゃないかなっていう気もしてきたんです
まぁ 考えてみると
この「町屋」っていう形式は
外圧が かからなかった江戸時代に
400年かけて
ゆっくり日本人の体にフィットしてきた
住居形式だったんですけれども
私たち 戦争を境にこの住居形式は
捨ててしまいました
今ある住居ってのは
たった70年です
また この写真は1926年に
ル・コルビュジエという建築家が
パリで発表した「ボアザン計画」というものです
これ 皆さんよくご存知の建物です
団地の原型ですね
これ 一つ一つが
一つの家族
一つの家族がコピーペーストされて
建物全体が出来ています
僕たちは知らないうちに
「この一つのユニットが家族だ」
っていうふうに
思い込んでしまってるかもしれません
この絵を見てると
日々日々使っている建築から
家族ってのはこういうもんだというふうに
教育されてるのかもしれません
さっき見てもらった
町屋のミセのように
「ここでゆっくりお話してってもいいよ」
というふうに
この建築は語りかけてはくれません
またある人が 秋田のおばあちゃんの
話をしてくれました
秋田のおばあちゃんは
山の向こうにある雲を見て
明日の天気が分かるそうです
今僕たちが暮らしている
住居っていうのは
「高気密 高断熱」って
言われてますね
魔法瓶みたいな
そういう住居です
そういう中で暮らしていると
もしかしたら
山の遠くの向こうまで
意識が及んでるっていう
この日本人が持っていた
感覚っていうのは
だんだん退化していっているかもしれません
最後に皆さんに この写真をご紹介して
終わりたいと思うんですが
これは村の人たちが協力をして
屋根を葺き替えている写真です
これ「屋根普請」といいます
「普請」というのは
お金がある人はお金を出して
材料がある人は材料を
体力がある人は体力を
みんなで協力し合って
一つの家を建てるというのが
言葉の意味です
昔 村では一軒 家を建てるのは
一大イベントでした
ですから 村の人たち
みんな協力して建物を建てました
みんなで協力して建てると
ここには みんな
気軽に立ち寄れるんですね
この写真のように
軒が深く出ていて
懐の深い土間があると
これは ある種
この村の公共の精神を現しているような
そういう たたずまいのように
思えてきます
またこの建築は
ここで過ごす時間っていうのは
ここの家族の人たちもそうだし
村の人たちも
ここから望める風景とか
ここに［降る］雨とか
雨とか風っていうのは
そういう人たちが
楽しむものとしてありました
もしかしたら人間はすでに
忘れてしまっている記憶が
こういうものにあるかもしれません
僕は 皆さんにとっても そういう
暮らしの中で
優しく語りかけてくれる建築が
あった方がいいなと
強く思っていますし
これからも僕たちはそういう建築を
作っていきたいなというふうに思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）